algunos lo denominan como un pacto
crucial y es que el acuerdo de
exportación de grano del mar Negro está
relacionado con la seguridad alimentaria
mundial ya que permite la importación de
grano y fertilizantes tanto rusos como
ucranianos desde puertos ucranianos un
flujo que se vio afectado por la Guerra
de Ucrania y que disparó los precios de
varios alimentos a nivel mundial y justo
para evitar eso en julio se planteó y
firmó el acuerdo mediado por la ONU y
Turquía permitiendo las exportaciones
desde tres puertos ucranianos Pero hay
un problema expira el próximo sábado y
eso ha levantado voces de alarma
el mundo necesita esto el mundo necesita
el acuerdo de grano del mar Negro y lo
sabemos porque hemos visto un mundo con
el acuerdo de grano del mar Negro y
también un mundo sin el acuerdo de grano
del mar Negro
Y es que la renovación está sujeta a
condiciones de la parte rusa ya que
Moscú asegura que a pesar de que los
productos rusos incluidos en el acuerdo
están exentos de sanciones siguen
sufriendo bloqueos
mientras la exportación comercial de
productos ucranianos se lleva a cabo a
un ritmo constante reportando
considerables beneficios que las
restricciones a los exportadores
agrícolas rusos siguen vigentes muchas
empresas de logística y transporte se
niegan a colaborar con los rusos algo
que podría hacer peligrar el acuerdo
global implica dos direcciones la rusa y
la ucraniana y ambas deben aplicarse
desde su firma el acuerdo ha permitido
la exportación de 23 millones de
toneladas de cereales el 55% destinado a
países en vías de desarrollo